Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica
Now, we are in the depths of HELL, and that's okay
which is weird to say, but it is okay because we are going to go into the primary research...
facility. Amongst all the death and destruction that is down here,
we DO have that to look forward to. But before I do that
I don't have enough resources to be able to build more lockers, so I just gotta read names, but anyway thank you to JFXAM who said,
"Mark, if Big Box Barry is about to blow up,
be sure to get in your prawn suit because you'll lose anything that's docked if the sub's health reaches zero.
You can salvage CYCLOPS parts, but not salvage what was docked.
and I don't think that matters anyway because if I lose this...I've lost everything.
If I lose this, I might as well start over, which I practically will be doing.
So I'm gonna make a VERY concerted effort not to lose this [laughs].
[to game] HI. How are you doing buddy?
[to audience] and then there's MarkDoesStuff who says, "Mark, don't think of these as caves. Think of it as a mouth of a really, really big monster."
And I am thinking of that now, and thank you. I didn't want to think of that. Thank you very much.
Then that guy yet again says,
"Mark, I swear every time you get that perfect times pants pissing,
it just makes the frantic yelling worth it."
Well, thank you!
I'd like to think that the game is programmed to respond to my freaking out nature.
And then GamingRemortay said,
"You should totally end the series by going Scuba diving deep in the ocean."
And you know what? That actually sounds pretty fun.
If I was actually able to do that—go into one of those shark cages and just sit in the bottom of the ocean,
kinda... figure out a way to film that, and piss my pants a whole lot?
I'll have a water reclamation suit after all!
But anyway! Enough skedaddling around. We gotta go...into here,
and I— I don't know why it's so dark all of a sudden?
I don't know why I can't see anything? It is, like, pitch-black, and I don't know why.
So, I'm just gonna—
[laughs nervously]
...try the camera system.
Eugh! Oh my God, what happened? It's so dark! [laughs]
It's so da—
[shouting] OHHH, HEY, HEY, HEY! HEY! HEY! HEEEEY!
I AM RIGGED FOR SILENT RUNNING!
[quieter] If you could not do that, that'd be greeeeat.
Oh...
Ahhhh, what am I hitting?!
[softly] Alright.
We're fine. We're fine!
Everything's fine!
Ohhh, I don't like that I don't know where the Leviathan went
[nervous] Where did Levi-y go?
[louder] Where did the Dargan go?!
Ah...
Oh...
This place is horrible
This place is the worst kind of place. Where IS he?
[Loud crash]
Oh, hi, okay, NOT necessary, buddy.
Oh, THERE you are. I'm headed straight FOR YOU!
Ohh, God. Okay.
HUH! We got to get in there. I'm gonna sneak around. I've got the blue key.
I've got the blue key! I've got the blue key, which I've been told is for this thing—
Hey. HEY.
Hey— HEY! Hey.
Enough!
All right? Enough. Oh, boy.
Ooh, that is a slow, lazy circling my— ohhhh, hi.
[nervous "oh" sounds]
Okay, all right. I am SILENTLY RUNNING!
OOOH, don't look at me!
FUCK how there's so much life down [here] with this asshole. [oh], god. Oh that guy got beat
That got beat into the primary research-
ohh
You're not coming, ha ha
ho ho ho hey hey hey
*shocked mark noise*
that guy got annihilated
*scream* why??
Ok, we're fine
[ok] he seems to be going over there was my chance to go in here. Sorry warper. You're about to get wham do oh
EUGH there are so many warpies why are there so many warpers? Oh boy. I don't know if I'm gonna make it here
I'm gonna try yeah, hi, okay. Hello. Hi. Go away, please ooh boy. Oh
Boy, everyone is getting a little sassy today now
Okay, get that squeezed a little too tightly there. Oh boy, okay? All [right]. You're fine. You're fine, and I'm fine. We're fine together. [oh]
Okay, I thought he was coming for me. Oh
screaming a little loud okay, I think we're in position, so if I
Go down get my blue am I silently running? I better I bet I better be rigged for okay good. I am, huh
[all] right, I just need to go down
Grab the key get in there
yeah, that's all I need to do should I take my
PRAWN suit?
[that] probably a good idea probably good idea let me just drop off some of the shit. I got in here. Oh
Okay, so this is all I need I should be good to go
Big Box Barry
Been a while right if I don't make it back well try to get home without me don't know if you can
But if you can try go for it, I'm just gonna save one last time before I go out of here. Oh
All right, let's do this [key] [opti]
Thank you. Oh don't do that. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Oh, no. Don't do this
You've done this before [don't] do this again. [so] you need the boink then you boink
Don't do that to me. Hey fucking hi who did that oh hi? Oh?
*mark screaming more*
No, no, no, no, I will fight you to the death whoa let me out here whoa boy
get in get in get in get in get in get in get in get in get in ah bam
huh, oh
fuck
Huh, okay
So I don't see I
Don't see an access panel anywhere around here
[ah]
All right, [I] don't [see] an access panel, but I see things in there. Which is different than it was before
So I'm gonna go in there. I just got to figure out how I guess I also need to fix up this guy
Sorry, big guy
Didn't mean for you get it hurt like that, okay
You see oh
*strange mark noises again *
as easy as that
They don't have any base here so all I did was [use] this same thing I used for the aurora
Hi, what the hell is that about okay?
man that guy is angry that I'm getting in here okay, so
What I should use as a disclaimer is to say that everything in here is temporary
So I'm not going to permanently be in here because it's not
It's not for me. Yeah unless
[I] have a compelling reason
not to oh my God, okay ah
yes, ah
Oh, hi. Sorry to be interrupting around here, but I'm just you know curious about what's going on
Hop out, that's a giant thing [ion], crystals that I could get if I wanted but I don't know if I necessarily want to
Because I kind of want to make everything temporary for now emperor project data
Let me just say
this device records data from the primary research specimen of this facility
According to the logs an indigenous life-form referred to as the emperor specimen was found to produce a unique substance they referred to as enzyme
42 which inhibited the symptoms of the infection in other indigenous
Organisms the Specimen was captured and contained here in addition to the eggs
it was found guarding the alien researchers went to great lengths to provide for the forms environmental needs including the import of
interdependent Flora and fauna
Via the on-site warpgate
However its health quickly began to deteriorate
At the time of the bacterial outbreak and result in quarantine [all] attempts to develop the [em] design into a vaccine had been unsuccessful
fascinating [I]
wonder why that is
Okay, [alright], then you do what you need to do. I really do wonder. Why that is why would there be nothing for that?
What is this? I don't know shall I scan you
Whaley and relic the markings on this device seemed to serve no purpose Beyond
Decoration and maybe the Alien equivalent of a lamp or magnifying glass used to examine other relics in more detail
Alrighty then Fancy there
Was this one another Lamp Yusei?
See despite its simple design this device contains enough potential energy to destroy the entire planet [the] most of the solar system
Fortunately it is malfunctioned. So why is it? Why is it on display here? Oh the aliens trying to do?
Little weird, and this one looks like some kind of bug oh
Or a turn this rock-like material features biomechanical parts that match components identified in the war pers accounted in four five or six [B]
Materials such as this may even have been fundamental building block of the aliens own self repairing mechanisms
Interesting I call it a [turd]
An Alien turd is what there seems like it seems like a museum for someone that doesn't know what's going on here
It is unclear
why technology of the
sophistication has not been found elsewhere on the planet its production may have been restricted or too costly or it may have been pillaged from
a more ancient civilization
That's weird to [think] about just a continuing like train of different older Alien civilizations here
I mean, it's entirely possible
this Alien device appears to be designed to eliminate all organic substances and arranged by emitting the Lethal but contained radioactive Field [I]
Good
I'm going to assume. That's good and everyone's going to be happy when that happens
I'm just kind of gone through this methodically. I don't know which one's gonna lead to where but I'm just gonna go in each door
Kind of find out for myself. [oh] ah
That's oh these must all be doors that lead to individual warp gate. Oh
Insert fuel crystal well time to go harvest some fuel crystals. I guess
Didn't know [that] now, okay didn't know that
I need to do that at least I can crack them open right here in the center and be enough to fuel all the warp
gates
Which is really really fascinating?
Because holy shit, okay can I oh I didn't need to jump apparently
Good news skeet don't mind me just finding up some nuclear material here
[super-Powerful] very fragile stuff could blow up everything to blow up absolutely everything
Yep
The pink Diamonds are enough to dis shatter this to pieces is the crux of all your alien technology
Let me just [lay] a hammer into it for my own personal gain
No, I'm [gonna] complain right?
So once I get a second put these into the teleporters and then activate it, but again
I don't know if I want to do this all yet because this is all
Temporary
Because it's not ready yet it it just like it's cool
Why is that like why? I don't know okay?
Okay, did I get them all oh?
unlimited
Are you kidding me unlimited? Oh my God this more relics over there? I'll get those in a second put on limited ah
It wasn't temporary [oh]
[God], [I] would I
Would okay let me just go back here
I'm gonna see what the fuck is up with this, and I'm gonna see where it goes cuz if I can go in it
I kind of want to see where it leads me uh
No idea skadoosh [woo]
Yeah, oh, that's that's a little off
Oh my God, so that's why I could never power them because they were never powered from the other side
whoa
Okay, well I went around the wall
Hello, whoa?
This is the Alien research one is just [what] this one is oh oh
That's so cool. [oh]
That's so cool. I will go back in just a second
I just want to see exactly where I am I'm 600 meters down
so I must be in the Lost River which must mean this is the
Lost River [research] [facility] right, but I don't remember this being here. I don't remember any of this being here. Oh
Oh, that's the same thing. Sorry. [oh], no, I remember this
I think maybe I don't know I don't know I know this isn't my primary objective right now, but I'm just too curious
Oh my God, oh
Oh, that's so weird. [I] don't even know what that is [oh]
that's so cool, but now ah but I don't ah [God] it's just [ah]
I'm trying to exercise a little bit of [self-discipline] here because it's not it's not ready. It's not ready
It's not ready because this is supposed to be
the end of the game like this area the Alien research facility or the primary research facility is supposed to be the
absolute end of the game ah
I pissed myself it was so exciting ah
But if it is the end of the game then I want to make sure that it's actually
Like all said and done before I actually do it
So I'm assuming that all of these chambers in here is going to hurt again now
Why did I do that, but all of these chambers in here must lead [to] other teleporters, right?
That's what they are so I don't need to go to all the whole
Well this one this one's different was oh
Okay, just bleeding through a little bit don't mind anything, err. Oh a little bit unfinished. That's why I said, it's not finished
whew
this device records all available physical data from a single point in time the last recorded data set was captured just after
Quarantine was imposed on the facility specimen Data the main containment Chamber here housed the CM
Leviathan and [it's] eggs the parent leviathans health have deteriorated it - eggs appeared to be in good [condition]
but in some form of natural Stasis
Alien structures the Data shows that within the vast specimen contained unit an incubation system had been constructed to house the leviathans eggs
Likely the Alien researchers have refocused their efforts to develop a [vaccine] on the unborn infants the [Incan] [basin] system
Incubation system suggests they had resorted to developing artificial hatching enzymes
Which would stimulate the natural hatching environment when quarantine was imposed all warped gates and access points [to] the facility were sealed
While the unborn emperor specimens may have held some potential for the development of vaccine
It is highly unlikely that parent or child survived having their food supply cut off and being isolated from the rest of their
Ecosystem
fascinating fascinating in this dark unlit room of which I don't want to be here, but that's also super cool because
It's like it's talking about this was a thousand years ago
[so] that's how these eggs survived the only way to survive was because they had [a] natural
Stasis and this must be another warp gate, but I just want to be certain
Like maybe the side Chambers are yeah, it is. Oh
But I don't I might as well activate it. You know you never know. Maybe I just feel so bad
I don't want to go. I don't want to do it all yet [ah]
oh
Well, you know it's here. I better stop
Warring with myself about it. You know I've never let it stop me before if I see something that wasn't ready yet
Because I didn't let that spoil the end experience because that's what this is about
[what] about the end experience seeing where it goes and where [it'll] take and that's what it is oh a sword, huh?
That's awfully
Softly ancient
Huh?
the in ancient Earth blade
Earth blade
Dated back to the 13th Century Mongolian Empire blood samples on the blade Matched the dNA of seven separate heads of state from the period
Why is there an Earth blade here are these are these just all
relics from Different Alien civilizations that looks like yin, and yang
Carving is a hundred of that hundreds of thousands of years old and made from an unrecognized natural fiber
Likely grown on and as yet undiscovered planet, so these aliens they were researchers
They were explorer. They were just exploring the galaxy trying to find things whoa
This weapon appears to be millions of years [old] and Matches no previously encountered technologies. It's weird cuz it look so simple
That bizarre, but you know enough [to] know it's a weapon I guess alien reliquary. That's just the holding tank that it's in
Cases composed of an impregnable translucent metal at the distant end of the periodic table scans do not reveal any contents
[Rightie] Haven is this lovely thing
beautiful this device is a rudimentary version of the keys used to access these facilities it may have been kept here [for] symbolic purposes or
Legacy support
Interesting so they developed new tech while they were here. I mean, that's what they must do
They must just salvage other tech this device for some point of communications relay apparently the objecting
The presence of the user to a remote location there do not seem to be any other devices in range
Oh, so just a communicator okay? Oh, I was about to say that looked on vanished, okay?
I'm gonna worry about the teleporters later
I just want to see if there's like something else here that I can get let me just drink some gas and
I'll wait for the food block. That's a last resort
Unfinished no, not unfinished, whoa
And what in der hack is deuce
whoa
some kind of pumping system probably for the
Arms right for the prize for the tank that they use for the emperor
This machinery is pumping water to and from the attached [Pipe] Network
Oxygen-deprived water is being flooded from the system analysis of the water composition flowing it indicates
It is being drawn from different biomes between here and the surface of the planet the water temperature is
Considerably lower than the volcanic environment outside the facility and oxygen-rich you mean to tell me okay?
This is this is astonishing if you think about it. You mean to tell me they have pipes
through the entire planet just
For pumping water number one, how did they dig the holes to be able to put in the pipes and number two?
How did they place the pipes after they dug the holes? How did they do that?
[I] mean of all the technological marvelous things. Oh, there's more down there of all the things that I've seen thus far that
Kind of raises [a] lot of questions, and I don't have any answers to that. Oh
And where did this come I?
Mean I know there's going to be like a long episode because there is so much to explore in here. Oh my God
That's not even done yet. That's the crazy thing. It's not done yet. Oh
It's huge. [oh] that's not done either. Okay? Well peer into the face of death. Oh my God. Oh
My God, that's so far down
Hey, buddy
How you doing down there you stuck yeah that you are
Okay, besides the other two teleporters that means there's only one more place to go or maybe two more places
I don't [know] this place is so confusing you never know which way you're going to go what I think I?
Think I may be close to getting to the [actual] place where the emperor his house
Which is really cool?
[alright] okay, so there's that place right [there], which is the thing and there's up there? So what is
over here
Whoa, what is that?
Okay, hang on
I'll come back for that because I don't want to use the unlock doors command just yet because I don't want to be disappointed or
Get there, too soon, because there's something else up here
It kind of leads towards the front of the building. I don't know what it is, but it's b. Whoa
okay, ha
What is is supposed to be in here?
Hmm. It Whispers in my mind
What is this? [oh]?
These are the eggs [oh]
And this one either got broken or it hatched
what the hell oh
Shell composition the shell casing is formed of thick layers of carbon
Composites suggesting an extensive gestation period The Leviathan species may give birth just once per century perhaps just once in their lifetimes
Precise incisions suggest a laser based tool was used to cut open the egg case and enforceable [Irri] move the fetus inside
prior to full
Gestation time pressure to develop a bacterial vaccine may have driven the alien researchers to cut open [this] egg and remove the fetus for study
Ha God, that's scary
And it is also possible that removed from its parent [and] natural habitat some vital condition for the infant to hatch naturally was not met
interesting
So it's safe to say that these
These fetuses probably did not slow hi, okay. That is suspect
Okay, hi
Okay
Dad that's weird
Don't know why that's happening. Okay? I'm just going to get out of here because that's freaking weird okay, so that
That is really fascinating
That's really fascinating
Super weird, but anyway. There's only one more place to go and I'm [going] to go there right about now
Funk soul brother [oh]
There it goes that's weird. It's weird weird, okay, and we go [oh]
And again, I'm very sorry for to all
vaccine development program terminated emperor egg hatching project terminated live specimens terminated evacuate immediately
oh
Well that [doesn't] sound very good
That sounds bad period Oh what the fuck?
What happens if I just don't in there? Hey? Oh?
Howie oh, Allie, [oh], maybe it was a bad idea to jump in here. Maybe it was a bad idea
[maybe] this was a bad idea. Oh, I'm gonna say this is a bad idea. Oh boy
What am I still in the water? What do I give the girdle?
Okay, I heard a little gurgle, and I didn't like that but okay well, okay skidoo sookie, okay, so either
Either [I] go up there, and I try to unlock that door or I go through here
Swings wrong, Georgia the dumb jungle Baby, whoa, not quite
Hope okay. Oh, there's nothing here ah
That's why it's just a wall let me try
this just in case
Yeah, it's just a wall whoa
Hello
Uh-Huh?
Hi, oh hi. Hello oh, hi. Hello hi, hi. Hello, hi
Hello
Hi, okay. All right. That's weird. Oh, wow oh
Oh, okay
Okay, okay, oh
oh, oh
Oh, big guy
Okay
All right, hi, oh
That's so cool. Oh
That's so cool
oh
It's so cool, and so scary. You're huge. [oh]
That's cool, though
Hi, oh my God and hang on. I'm about to run out of oxygen
I brought my uh I brought my pron suit over here
For just such an occasion. [oh]
my God
Okay, all right then hey you brewski hello hello hello, okay Clippers Captain, okay? All right
Seasons it's so weird it's so okay. All right. Hi hello, okay?
I'm just gonna fall. I guess I'm gonna be [able] to get out of here now, but okay. Oh boy
Bumfuck oh
Those your eggs. Oh
[oh]
That is Frickin hair flying that is terrifying and those are huge [oh]
Those are huge ion, crystals. Oh my God
That's so weird, [and] these are your eggs these are you guys?
Detecting Unusually passive Behavioral Patterns and nearby Predators reason unknown [oh]
Don't look at me like that. Oh
Don't look at me like that oh, hi. Hello. Are you coming in oh hi? Hello? Hi Heidi, Heidi, Heidi, oh
Okay, [oh] boy. Oh, hI. [all] right? Hello oh hi. Oh
oh
scary
Wow, that's scary. Oh, that's terrifying do you want me to?
use this
You want me to oh?
Oh, I didn't bring those oh, I didn't bring those
hatching enzymes mysterious enzymes from Creepvine Sample, oh
I don't have that oh my God. Oh
Man, that's so weird
What would happen if you use this if I actually brought creepvine down here and use them with the hatching enzymes?
Like, what would I do?
[I] was so weird
What do you say chell uncommon ly strong?
Shell lining organic growth on the [x-series] suggests these eggs may be hundreds of years old
Alien devices penetrate the outer layer of the she'll likely designed to supply them with nutrients and isolate them [from] the surrounding environments
Unlike most eggs where a nutrient supply is slowly exhausted by the Embryo these eggs exist in a form of natural
Stasis likely awaiting ideal hatching conditions fetal organism
There's a high genetic match between these organisms in the leviathan in the vicinity
they appear to be stable and [healthy] it is likely that ideal hatching conditions vary considerably from ideal conditions for
survival of the parents the local Ecosystems appears to have prioritized elaborate
weird
All that look it out, so weird, oh
man, oh
man the [Jambo] hi
Hello, okay, all [right] then see ya ah so you are waiting to see what I would do
to the eggs ah
So what would happen if I did this would it mean anything if I did this now, [I]?
Don't [know] and that's the thing right. [I] don't know because all of this is unfinished
Like even this it tastes wrong
You know what I mean because I didn't earn this yet. I didn't earn any of this I
don't know what all this means because I
Didn't get here like legitimately
And he's coming back [just] to say hi to me because I'm he's waiting to see what I could do, but it feels wrong
you know what I mean, I'm right on the cusp of something here, and I I
I can't bring myself to go get hatching enzymes and do this because it's not
here yet, and
I'm not going to cheat and get him like I'm not
Refused to do that. I've already cheated enough thus far and
This all ties in to why I said this was [ten] Rarey. I said in the beginning of this episode
[I] said that this was temporary and here's why?
I'm going to make a decision that's going to be very unpopular popular with a lot of people, but [I] have reasons for it
When [I] set out to make this new adventure in Subnautica about what is it 40 50 episodes ago?
I set out [to] do this because I wanted to experience everything
Everything there was in subnautica and the tragic [thing] about it. Is that it is early access and that means that things are unfinished
Again, I set out on a journey that was futile in the beginning because it was not all there
And I had some hopes that they might finish the game
But the game is not released yet
And even here right on the precipice of what could potentially be the end of the game?
it doesn't feel right if I were to get enzymes cheat with them and see that right then and there and
You know why it's because I wouldn't have earned it
The beautiful thing about me playing this game up until this point
Is that I had earned everything and I felt so bad in the past three episodes that I've had the cheat to unlock doors
Because I didn't earn that. It didn't feel right
It wasn't right because it wasn't ready
And I've pushed some boundaries getting in here because I know you guys wanted to be in this room with that [Si] emperor and seeing
What happens when you hatch these eggs, but to be perfectly honest. I don't think anything would because it's not done
And it's not ready
And I don't know for certain. If it is or isn't, but I'm going to end this here
this is it for subnautica for now and
I know that's sad to hear and it's sad [for] me to say because I've had so much fun on this journey
But I've had fun on it
because of the way
I did it and because of the the like amazing things that I saw along the way and because of the
Hardships that I had to go through to be able to get to this point. That's what makes games fun
It's a fantastic world, and you have to earn it. That's the beautiful thing behind it
and
That's what makes it so sad when you have to say goodbye
You know I mean this emperor is looking at me looming over me in
Huge the biggest [thing] I've seen yet in the game
and I cannot cheat I will not cheat and
I will not even go out and get this stuff and see if it will work here not because [of] the time it'd be easy
with the teleporters, but just because
It's not ready
So this is the end of the road for me in subnautica. I know there's been a long speech
I didn't prepare it or anything
But I just wanted to justify to you guys why I am setting subnautica down for now because it is not done
It's all temporary
But it will be done soon
when the game goes live
And it actually has an ending when it [actually] has everything done here
I will revisit this game, but until then I have to say goodbye for now and
again, I know that's not going to make a lot of people happy, but it's what's right and
[it'll] be even better when you earn it when I earn that ending when I earn what's here when I earn this
like when I earn the answers to all the questions in my mind when I earn them [it'll] be so much more satisfying and
[it'll] be so cool. But don't worry. I'm not when I pick it back up
I'm not going to start a new game, and it's not going to be another 50 episodes. That's why I said everything was temporary
I'm not going to save after this I'm going to end it here [and] I'm a restart
Back in the old save make sense it should be well worth the wait
[so] thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you think of this down in the comments below and
As always I will see you in the next video
Bye, bye